what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
a fan of mine named yin-yang said hey
Rob
I saw someone at Point Lobos in
California who looked just like you
well the reason why you saw someone who
looked just like me is because it was me
oh you should have said something you
should have walked up and be like hey uh
are you by chance coming to explain that
would have been like yes because I love
meeting fans anybody who's met me
god I love meeting you guys I love
talking to you guys and hanging out with
you guys that's why I love going to
comic book conventions by the way I will
be at PAX West
if anybody happens to run into me there
but anyway we are continuing our series
on Omega level and beyond Omega level
characters now those of you guys who
were not familiar with my YouTube
channel if you've just stumbled across
this video because you're like asking
what Omega level and Beyond Omega level
was originally a Marvel Comics term and
it was a term used to describe the most
powerful mutants in existence this term
was expanded to non mutants and said
they were simply referred to as Omega
level threats for example for is an
Omega level threat because of all the
strength and power that he has the
Incredible Hulk is an Omega level threat
Hyperion who will probably do next week
and is basically Marvel Superman P is
you know an Omega level threat all these
characters are Omega level threats what
we do on this series is we take that
general term and we apply it to every
character across all comic book mediums
who are crazy powerful so like divinity
from Valiant Comics is crazy powerful in
the last video we talked about the
wizard Shazam the one that gave Billy
Batson his power so he could shout
Shazam and become a superhero he's crazy
powerful so in this video we are going
to be talking about the chaos King and
while the chaos King is a little bit
obscure he's crazy powerful so I think
the best way to explain how powerful the
chaos King is is to basically trace his
major appearances within Marvel Comics
now he's only been around for a little
over a decade and during that time he
appeared only a few times so going
through his major story arcs is not only
going to give us a better understanding
of his history but it's also going to
allow us to discuss most of the feats
that he's performed so that we can get a
sense of how powerful he is in relation
to the rest of the Marvel Universe plus
I think it just makes for a more
interesting video if we can actually
discuss what his character is done and
Just Giving like a laundry list of
powers and you know all that kind of
stuff and so basically what we'll find
out is this guy can do anything he wants
to
so the chaos Kings true name is a Matsu
me Kobashi
and he was created by Michael oming and
his first appearance came in Thor blood
oath number six in 2006 and was based on
the Japanese god of chaos of the same
name now when he's first introduced he
simply presented as the Japanese god of
evil and not much about him is explained
at that point however later that year
the chaos king as a character would be
fleshed out far more in death in a
miniseries that oming had wrote called
Ares God of War
now what happens during that event is
that Ares who's basically the Greek god
of war within the Marvel Universe has
simply grown like ashamed of all the
death and violence carried out in his
name so he left Olympus for a life on
earth where he just lives like a regular
you know loses a regular person he has
like a job as a contractor and he's
raising his son named Alexander why he
would choose to be a contractor I don't
know I would be like you know what I'm
gonna live a normal life as like a
billionaire like that's what I would do
but one day a messenger of the Greek
gods named Hermes visits Ares and tells
them that he has to return to Olympus
because it's being threatened by
something the likes of which they've
never seen and the gods need his help to
defeat it now Ares initially refuses and
so in order to coerce him into coming to
their aid Zeus kidnaps the son of Ares
Alexander and brings him to Olympus is a
pretty douche move like is a pretty
crappy thing to do and so predictably
this enrages Ares enough that he does
return to Olympus to retrieve his son
but when he gets there he finds out that
Alexander has been kidnapped once again
from the cell where he was in prison and
so it turns out that the person who took
Ares son was also the very threat that
the gods were pleading with Ares to help
them defeat the chaos king who is
basically hoping to brainwash Alexander
so that he will kill his father and
replace him as the god of war under
chaos Kings control now in order to
rescue his son Aerys agrees to help the
rest of the gods in their fight against
the chaos king and what we learn is that
following the fall of Asgard and the
death of all the Asgardians and the
Norse gods in the Ragnarok storyline the
chaos king was inspired to defeat in
control as many pantheon of gods as he
possibly could and having already
subdued the ancient Japanese pantheon
he now had his sights set on the Greek
gods so to that end the first power we
learn of the chaos king is that he's
able to instantaneously transport armies
to a desired location which he's done to
the Greeks taking them by surprise and
killing a multitude of their warriors we
also learned that the armies he commands
are made up of those he's killed so he's
able to basically resurrect the dead and
then force them to do his bidding we
also get an idea of how powerful the
chaos king is because we see him
mortally wound Zeus who is the most
powerful of all the Greek pantheon now
because of this we know that chaos King
ranks higher in terms of power than Zeus
and the other sky fathers in the Marvel
Universe like Odin and Vishnu now if
you're new to Marvel Comics the sky
fathers are basically a group of gods
who represent modern-day gods so like
the God of Abraham so to speak I think
his word is like Yahweh or something
along those lines
Vishnu Odin Zeus so on and so forth
they're just like a really powerful
group that exists they don't really
interact that often they just meet up
every once in a while like when Thanos
got the Infinity Gauntlet Odin call him
together and he was like man there's a
popping off man like we need to do
something there was nothing they could
do
they all got wreck it was pretty messed
up but what we end up finding out is
that later on Zeus had healed from his
injuries and so he confronts the chaos
king but the chaos king absorbs Zeus's
attack without any injury and responds
by ripping out his heart seemingly
killing him now although we found that
the chaos king is crazy powerful he's
not completely invulnerable as he's
defeated when Alexander is freed from
the chaos Kings control and uses the
grass cutter sword a mythical Japanese
blade on him and appears to kill the
chaos king although we know that this is
not the case because he would basically
show up later on after having been
resurrected now following this apparent
resurrection the chaos King continues
his quest to eliminate as many pantheon
of deities as he can and it's revealed
that the reason for this is that the
chaos King existed before the formation
of the Marvel multiverse essentially
before the multiverse emerged there was
nothing but a void and in that void the
chaos king thrived so his plan was to
eliminate the various divine pantheon to
bring about a new age of nothingness and
chaos so on the way to accomplishing
this he's recruited by a group known as
the God Squad which was a team formed by
the
Council of godheads a council largely
made up of the sky fathers were the most
powerful gods that exists in these
various Pantheon's to basically fight
the scroll pantheon of gods now the God
Squad made up of Hercules Amadeus Cho
Snowbird and various others along with a
supposedly reformed chaos king defeated
the scroll gods with me Kobashi
appearing to die in the battle however
this proved false and the chaos king
took the form of the leader of the
scroll gods and in took control of the
rest of the scroll slave army to aid him
on his quest to destroy the entire
multiverse so it was really kind of a
cool ruse that he played but after this
the chaos King continued on his path of
destruction which we see play out and
probably the most popular of his
appearances a 2010 event known as the
chaos work and is during this event that
we really see just how powerful the
chaos king is because we see the vast
amount of destruction that he's capable
of he kills numerous pantheon of gods
including the Egyptian gods the Celtic
gods and the Shiar gods as well as the
gods of zenn-la the homeworld of the
Silver Surfer he journeys to the dream
dimension and kills its leader nightmare
a villain who has routinely given dr.
strange a run for his money
this causes most of the Earth's
population including its mortal heroes
to fall into a sleep-like state and so
slipping into the territory of totally
ridiculous he even goes into Hell and
destroys Mephisto effectively Satan
himself and casts mistress death out of
hell the entity that represents died she
is believed to be immutable
indestructible so on and so forth but
the power of the chaos King was so
extreme that she just fled for her life
as soon as he showed up and so following
this all the souls of the Damned are
freed to run amuck on earth under the
chaos Kings control now the few heroes
that are left awake on earth Hercules
Amadeus Cho and Thor scramble to find
anyone who can help them defeat the
chaos King and call upon the cosmic
entity eternity which is basically the
embodiment of all living things in the
entire Marvel Universe now as hercules
attempts to convince eternity to help
them in their battle against the chaos
king eternity informs them that he's
unable to fight because doing so would
effectively be eternity fighting himself
and explained that eternity and the
chaos king are essentially two sides of
same coin that eternity represents
everything and the chaos king represents
absolutely nothing eternity admits
however that if the chaos king is
victorious that he'll simply cease to
exist so we know that chaos king is
every bit as powerful as eternity
but he has the power to erase eternity
from existence God would need to cover
this story now eventually Hercules
recruits Cersei Galactus and the Silver
Surfer to his cause however all of them
working together even after Hercules has
received power from some ancient
artifacts collected by Amadeus Cho still
cannot defeat the chaos king let me
reiterate that the combined efforts of
God Hercules the most powerful version
of his character that we've ever seen
this guy would would just decimate The
Incredible Hulk
god Hercules Galactus and Silver Surfer
could not beat the chaos king and so
eventually Amadeus Cho and Galactus
figure out a way to create a portal to a
bubble dimension of absolute nothingness
and Hercules manages to summon every
ounce of his power and punch the chaos
king into that dimension where he can
basically exist surrounded by nothing
which was his desire all along and
that's the last that we ever see of him
but it's pretty obvious that the chaos
king is way beyond Omega level and is
one of the most powerful entities and
the Marvel multiverse now I know we
haven't really talked about what his
specific powers are yet in any real
measure of detail so we'll go into those
you know super fast so obviously he has
your standard run of ability
super-strength SuperSpeed
invulnerability
and he's basically immortal since he's
existed since before the creation of the
multiverse and we haven't seen anything
in Marvel Comics that can permanently
kill him he can resurrect himself and
others and control the minds of those
that he raises from the dead he can
teleport himself in thousands of other
individuals instantaneously he can alter
his size and shape and become invisible
he can create shadow copies of himself
he can travel between dimensions he can
destroy and enslave even the strongest
of opponents including gods and can
destroy entire universes as well as
Jesus Christ this guy's powerful he was
said to have destroyed over 98% of the
multiverse before being shunted off to
the bubble universe of nothing
so yeah this guy is Opie to say the
least
chaos king is crazy powerful yeah what
do you do with a character like that
because I mean I gotta be honest man a
guy with a power like this I'd say maybe
the only person that would really be
able to give him like a run for his
money barring you know someone like the
one above all would probably be Marquis
of Death and even then there's no
guarantee so like this dude
this dude's Opie but anyway guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like leave a comment down
below let me know who you guys want me
to cover after Hyperion
Hyperion's basically Marvel Superman so
we're gonna cover him next Friday but
let me know what care do you guys want
me to cover next and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]